Why. Well i'm i'm talking to
mr.
Jackman rowe who worked on the sydney
harbour bridge in his younger years during
the building of the bridge. Do you member
getting the job there first. Do you mr.
Monroe date. No. Do you remember when you
got the job does brightly what do you
think it would be and be
a nineteen early 1927 and who who
who did you go and see to get the
job. Sen. Claire mr.
Sinclair. He was a foreman was he. He was
a general foreman indoors
point that day because i
couldn't say the day. No i wouldn't know
but you remember what happened that day he
said start in the morning
ish say jack brandished
a down in the office. That was wet
and the vehicle of farriers used to
start. And what was the job you
had to do. He sent me up to
charlie foley he was foreman of the
of the men under sinclair and what
was what job did you have to do. He
sent me i want to deregulate. Had you
a bit of rigor before i had to read or
into regulatory variants. Where was there
in casual jobs around shed any and i
i was doing
a job on land the high tension
cables from dawes point under
the dome to the harbour was it or i want
to just longside harbour. This is what i
did and i have to think that of people to
name. There's friend was in charge was
a diver albert diver a
woman and he would lay
a mic cables from north point
over to make my point and
he was
a friend of my mother's the
other young man. And i
was down with my auntie mrs.
Norton and i come down on the
tram where we are to catch
the ferry from the manas
point of course to
look. And i welcome she she said this
is when she when i got out of the tram
and dawes point. To catch the
parry. She knew that the eyebrow
button will do and he was in charge of
the land the cables under the harbor
and. When when we got out of the tram
there were puncheon and men
working from the punch list of about
twelve o'clock on the day. And
aunty said to one of the boys to work and
one of the men i should say if i have are
amarilla and we've just got out
of the tram. There he is on
a punt out there which interested.
Would you mind telling him and this is
agnes naughton she knows
me i'd like to say
that i will bring him over brought him
over and. This is my nephew jack.
An issue at all. Words she said and
it's like
a job. Or words to that effect
how you can start now. I
remember that. And you know i don't i
can't do that and i did in the morning.
Alrighty then. Report over to
dawes point. And power strip
in the morning which i dead
and i wrote my mind and job
there until it cut out but it had not had
a head and started somewhere
else and later on. I've gone
concern with the work going on at the bridge
where there is to turn off right well
we were well. And found out about mr.
Sinclair's name on choir about
a job and that later on of this got sound
and had how i started to work on the
bridge. I went and seen him and he said
you can start in the morning next day and
he sent into remission. Mr.
Breen and i stopped there for quite
a while until we come out on
strike and that he sent me
out on i think that is correct.
Next morning i started called
and jack brain and jack brain was
the man in the operation. It was
a very much and and gent
my aunt do you know.
Charlie finally he was in charge of the
rigors and i'd had ability to be injured
and of reagan and they went around and.
How other man. We were in
a box where would you call and.
Or like
a cage biographical. And our
names although i believe
black all came from tasmania.
Bob david come from our summer away
. Max
and my show. Jack munro where did make
certain come from. Do they were free money
come from england. I did worry it was
down and sydney i don't know that i would
live in
a crow's nest. Anyway. Was that where
your aunt lived and where and. I
remained in that job for quite
a while. So what do you did you start
you think about only twenty six or
twenty seven was it due to
a disease. How only twenty seven and
what did you do actually do in the job. I
went straight end of the reagan. So what
was the job. What you have to actually do
either general joe did but emotionally i
was mostly look i'm after
the crane man with
a bill. You know the
cream driver's name and i'm trying
to think of it knowing very well.
Was that the one that you said lift the the
stone off of the ships or was it one up
on the top then he was
up top. I mean. Mostly
charlie riche you've got your own charlie
riche and i remain with them and tell
trust i am as i know i. Which came
to me give. When you actually
used to act as dogman for that green driver
would you do you ride the load all the
time. Oh wait. Mostly they have
a lot. Tenant of em all the time and ride
their load or not. Did you right on top
of the low. I stood on
a loud no and waited up. Under the
supervision of charlie campbell and how high
or whatever heights they were working on
here might be mantra for leadership the
crane you see if you only take it in spasm.
That's on the on the on the approaches
or on the lot itself when it
started to go up but not on
what you call it there. I've got
a photo of it in there and you want the
pylon is it. When you leave the pile of
matter vag. I was
a own help to screw up the nut
should i go to the pylon with
a big big spanner i never forget
that day. And now i don't.
And you were on the approach spends as
well. Working on the proto pens in sit in
the city. Weren't you the side. I
started and doors point. Had we had
a welcome. And we laid
every layer the rails for
the for the for the crane
that drive the trolls on
to do. Did the carpenters build up beforehand
you remember the carpenters working
there and i knew them. I knew them
personally. Yeah that was false. Work it was
taken away afterwards was not that a pull
it all down and actually had a build
a bridge of hollywood could do the
steel work. Do you remember actually
how they did that you member them doing
it. Did you. That tembo work. Yes well
that was our special gang of more
or less but we helped. And overhead
part of that. Nina never have
a gantry along the side to walk along the
street because you don't get the other
men were going to barbee a little what
we used to call a steelworkers at
a river which was quite
a lot. And i still remember once like
there's no matter of fact i don't know what
he's gone. How many belonged really the
club and sydney where i. And afterwards.
Where where i belong to this day is the
new shout way old room ladies club.
So it was his name. Jim
you know i know i'm
sure. Well you know no way
to letting their i have
a moan. I can't i can't think of something
else and durable did you know any of the
other steel workers at all the metal workers
you member jack mccrae he worked on
the pile on hand member him job
he did. Oh general. I mean.
Well you can say well nearly all
labors were not when we had
a go where directed but i'm i was i more
or less but then the one going all the
time. And shorten and story are
up until the day all is down.
Who's to come and elevators up and then
go on down into the abutment shortage of
correct word. And that was pretty
fleet under the harbor and i took
a hundred tons of concrete in there. And
were you working at that time on
only out one day they were even
a block and that was
tear and bags recommend
a tremendous open that all i done. And
i recall this one once while i worked
with it. Over the period of
time i got up to ninety nine
buckets
a day of life. That's concrete and skips
you. And you can call it what you like
our money trying to think you know
he is people we are now. And we
come on about about three tana left
and i as they got was ninety nine
lives of ships. You know
day she was surrounded and
a lot. But they never got 100.
That was before they got off
the ground level was this cuba acts.
Yeah cuba and they went down into the
rock and rock solid
what you call strollers
samson own. Do you remember them digging
the tunnels for the for the cables
to the hell they're doing
their. Yes. Now adam there
but need to describe them
very hard and it's something
that he can't talk
quick on drugs. You remember
it took a long time to build
a bridge and you could only do
it and have it done against
a day in lengthy work i reckon
they were pretty smart. You
know that's only in in time. Yes
you know what else what else
were you involved in do you think about
from the two you responsible for lifting up
the steel worker. No i had nothing to
do with a steel nothing to do with
a known. I stopped and that gang were all
of us together. What about this loan were
the maria stern that used to come
off the ships involved with ed only
and the senate types down there which
was sixteen ton in what we went up to.
Selected and this was a main
part of our work. I thought it
a great honor to take for men. I'd
put michelle the demand then of
running
to be our job or to lift the red block
rig blocks and this would work came from
the from the mill and we had there by the
carpenters correct the
block which was to live
this main down was left we've all
get on it but the senate how
they call today in my own place and mine
by sunni and we were sent up they are
selected to do not for direct the
blocks which were to attempt ten ton
blogs to live that. Up had lowered into
place. That's the all star and it's
a big one. And to remove the
stonemason who was working with you. I
don't know and they were all scotchwoman
or he was an italian this one. And this
name was for everyone to the kid each
year. And some name like that. I guess it
wasn't as gods when he was an italian. Our
dunno but i tried to mould god's name
and they've never been all scotchman anyway.
They were and that's where they were
just with
a stone mason and no john
mckay yeah and you hear
him by scribe i never never had anything
in the work in line with him. I'm back
with a story with
a senator who was sixteen ton
and not. Down and we had you to
ten ton blocks to live. I'm lowered
into place for the stonemasons.
And week naturally we stopped and then
a done by on. Which we didn't have
to return to work. We went home
from there but one thing i think about and
days were pretty tough. Then too we were
paid over that day and the honourable men
to shut out unveiled. And i'm proud to
say that that was in 1927 when gerry
lang was that really it wasn't
a couple of years later when it was
actually and then. Well i wasn't in and
that's about all i can tell you about it.
When i went down on the strike that. Ij
money that was called by the riggers when
the artery that taken place. Yes and
. It took time and i thought
well. Have they gone out of our
way. Who will whined that up that what
they said would be settled by then
so i decided to come home and see my marlon
and cole back. I met this gentleman and
my father knew and was friends of ours and
he talked me into the job. I took and
i never went back to doormen. And so you
have been here ever since burma if you.
And one off you know i'm not i mean my
home repair my share of during the war for
three years. And i had my
hire car then and act as
a nam once and he's in charge of the policeman
any tom dick and harry and i kept my
idolization zolo got when i got off
the ship to take it and that was
a 1927 and i still have not to this
day would have same number and
from the same address with a
none blemish record without even
a part on conviction and that's i have to
do this right. Day november the fifth day
in 1988 that vera enough
he used to be so happy i want to know
anything from my private life and i i i cared
that job on the day talked me into
and i was a first man a card logs by
a truck which i have
a folderol that here today and as
a mail. He done that job for about
about fifteen months when we're you
born and how we're born in bagram and
what you have
a view of your father and mother. What
was your father my father when we were
property owners cattle you know
they are farmers. And you mother
she come from
a family. Now you come from hotel
family and you were born in she
was born in and
. Not through an explosion on around
here was no way up in the batter's
way what's a place where they found
a big nugget what some yellin
she was born and then elin
and mother had a hotel there
then and the day that by
a granola and i found that bag now got the
biggest you know record of it. World i
think and they brought it up in
and put it on mothers bar mothers
mothers. And that's the only light and
still left in element and they were the
royal i think at least sure that's
a name the royal of the hotel name on them
was only one there all things are gone
now. That we're byron oldham
and mother and my father were
born and harold on another
another goal there in
russia today. This family arrived
there in the gold rush period.
Apparently they were born they were born.
How are you going to your schooling where
did you go to school i went to school and
beg you lived in bigger better on their
side bigger you know right in the
town. We had a property they had
a race course where supplied
a milk direct there then for
the delivery. I can't retire
and how long the school were when did you
leave school. I didn't leave school or
about fifteen. What did you like
to school and what didn't you like
that and i got it. Once i remember when we
had our hand run right and i went to the
primary school was died but you're in your
road and graders as time went on and we
had a and a teacher. There she was
a sister of the editor of
the bagel paper and and
winners mornin. I hope you had your
elbows on the honor. What is not
a cow not what economy on the desk on the
dash that's ahead on the dad and she come
along and but the ordinary foot
roller. I don't talk football and
don't change it in the names of what it
is today and she wouldn't have the real
flat if you did
a john have you hands are on
the desk. I never forgot that
and. Naturally we graded to
different teachers and i went to
far as i could say in this school old age
that we had no school as it is today.
What subject as you like best
buy and store it our the holidays what
you call it. Composition or their
composition our like. And
so will you work first.
If we work your father first do you know
why would i would wear them with me fala
before i would work and
why we work on. Later on
when i left school was far no natural hours
spent most of my dime of school at my
age for no today. But when
when i knocked or booth and
a school i was malcolm couch
brother nine hundred ten
a day twice
a day by hand until we sold out when
that was reported i went to didn't he
say or i got paid for for norman on
. She went straight to sydney. Oh no no
you're working there and you know when you
went to tada and dad bought
a place down there just do to retire in
history and he wasn't satisfied and that he
here he took us away in
a lot of vision. Up up the coast. He was
going to buy another pub or another
farmers ramón we seen several pater didn't
show them. Benchley come back to tata
we were renting
a place down there then and the
president property up to it was stolen
travel yeah that remain
as if we had retired it
had retired and boy we used
to be take cattle job like
and they used to be. Gassaway
action by then and the phylicia
come down coal and it was dumped
a special broder bring it down and it's all
current up on the point long stride of
us and we used to get bob a load allowed
a bullock wagon six bob mind
and. It has to be carted to
beaver. That's eleven miles from
tightrope. And with no casual
work like a madman got
a job. Look follow around or try and
many border trucks. We went up to
to top of the mountain being that call.
No moneyball and i had to
help them load temblor
from their go end and the
railway matches whenever built
in canberra most of it was
went there before i went to shin
up to then i got to sydney another
back and this is where i am now.
So what do you were you born then i born
a nine one five and when did
you leave for sydney first
then today or no. Was it after he was off
the first result of the first world war i
am. I went to sydney and
i told you and i got
a job. Yes. But during the first
world war you member that
i go into school i remember
the first time i got to
not get out and whatever call it when you
come round put us kids through all this
business. I remember the first
world war when they they had the
plague that was just war finished
up it i mean yeah bubonic flu
. We're all we're all
quarantined for quite
a while. Pneumonic flu. Ham.
If you remember when you
were when you left the bridge and
came back to to. Well not burma q.
You came back the trigger did you and where
did you come back to live then i was
boarded tell you what it is and what he
was your first job when you got my job as
a man a talk me and a minister to stop
me gone back to dorman long. I bought
a new truck discard away
from the horse teams and
insisted art and me so many times we landed
on the warburton birmingham. And i had
booked through that data and then the ship
used to blow free western and then about
every quarter hour because you carried
all impassioned and. I had no show
along for some reason or other astron or i
don't and won't know. Get me port. I run
up the gangway and down into to meet cameron
and get reported and bring it up on
the wharf. And then he brought me up without
tell pretty good who were unloading
the ship and he said well come back and get
the truck he said and he said i'll fix
you. Lighten up. He said with
a policeman the policeman used to visit
the wharf there and boat and big time the
ship would come in and i said that will be
ok i'll take the job number went back to
sydney and then. When it went he booked
me and up can oversized party had
a room them and i worked at jobbers until
1920 and the tender come out for the
mail and along the coast and
i put in for it and got.